today's topic FIFA World Cup
going to where the World Cup is
currently happening in Qatar men's World
Cup and there's been a lot of
controversy surrounding the fact that
it's happening in this tiny Middle
Eastern country the World Cup itself is
mired in a lot of controversy because a
lot of migrants were brought into work
to build the stadium and all the
facilities for the World Cup
um a lot of them reportedly have died as
a result of the working conditions also
people have cited the fact that there's
a lot of
anti-lgbtq laws anti-alcohol laws which
makes it unfit to be a location for the
World Cup and so now all this muggled
together people are having a lot of it's
been happening for quite some time but
now that's actually happening all the
focus is on the fact that you know Qatar
is a bit of a [ __ ] up place I'm gonna
play a video from the president of FIFA
the people who actually gave Qatar the
rights to be able to host the World Cup
and listen to what he says
today I feel
Arab
today I feel African
today I feel gay
big what the [ __ ] did you say I don't
know where the hell you was going with
this one
but uh when I hear you speak
the only thing that comes to mind is hey
I heard you was a wild one
oh
[ __ ] today I feel disabled
if this is some kind of Kumbaya thing
where it's like We are the world we are
the world I don't want to hear it you
don't want to hear anything he's the
children because he's about to say it
today he feels like a children that's
why I get to [ __ ] 13. whoa
if you think about it that's the
argument
today I feel disabled
today I feel
a migrant worker
as a child at school
I was bullied because I had red hair and
I had this red how do you call them
freckles freckles freckles sorry
freckles freckles you see I don't even
know the term
I was bullied
of course for that plus I was Italian so
imagine
didn't speak good German
and what do you do then
you lock yourself down you went to your
room you cry
and then you try
to make some friends
and you try to speak to engage and you
try to get these friends
to engage as well with others and others
and others
don't start
accusing fighting
insulting
you start engaging uh we've learned that
it's not because you make a whole heap
of money that you should be talking
it's not because you're the president of
anything that sort of faces the thing
and then you should be talking
how many of these uh
European or Western business
how many of them
have addressed migrant workers rights
this moral lesson giving
one-sided
it's just hypocrisy
if you're confused by what the [ __ ] is
happening just know FIFA was paid a
pretty penny and by Penny I mean
billions of dollars to do this make no
mistake they'll sit up there open up
their anus to let Satan roll through if
it meant they made a few extra billion
these people are hell's incarnate on
Earth they are disgusting they engage in
all kinds of forms of corruption at the
highest level and they don't care about
nothing but money but what is this
what is what what is that what is what
what is going on I don't know if he's
that sickness I think for what we
Europeans have been doing in the last
3000 years
around the world we should be
apologizing for next 3000 years before
starting to give moral lessons
it's not because you have a valid point
meaning
whatever
happened in the past in your base you
saw from facts that happened back then
you know that it justifies
you deflecting everything that you're
deflecting and what happened in Qatar
I'd be like yeah let's not blame Qatar
because we [ __ ] up too
so let's not blame them no I think you
should be blamed up but both of y'all
should be blamed
that's it you can't deflect
[ __ ] be like yeah no we did
this in the past so when we do that
right now so
don't judge
yeah no
no I understand where you were coming
from what you try to use all right good
but no what happened two thousand one
thousand two hundred years ago has
nothing to do with the fact that qataris
or killing people as recently as last
year okay the two things are not
analogous they're not the same stop
wasting my time with that [ __ ] you want
to have a discussion about European
colonization and its effects go ahead it
has nothing to do with the fact that the
very place that people are buying
tickets and going to is one made from
what
pretty much slave labor
okay the borderline okay
there's a giant difference between me
going to America a country founded on
slaves a long time ago and then enjoy my
time there and go into some [ __ ]
place of Qatar where the blood of the
people still hasn't dried a [ __ ] at his
difference that's different
not the same
say it okay and you can make the
argument that a lot of these countries
whatever the dark history is they've had
made some form of restitution to some
degree or they've evolved to some degree
qatar's still in the past [ __ ] it's not
a positive that you are a reflection of
the past of these European colonizing
countries like it's not a good thing oh
yeah how you gonna talk [ __ ] about me
[ __ ] uh I was you 200 years ago
yeah [ __ ] grow up
this issue even though it's becoming a
hot bun topic now Nick
this is crazy
I made a video four years ago talking
about maids in the Middle East and how
people would be hired as servants yeah
okay from uh Asia from Africa and they
get brought all it's not even a Qatar
thing let me be clear okay some of these
servants were brought to like Lebanon
Syria Saudi Arabia what ends up
happening is people who need to get jobs
or want to get jobs for their family get
brought to these countries okay
through agencies and then once they get
brought there in order for them to not
be able to leave and then to be really
subservient their passports get
confiscated their pay gets withheld
because they send the money back for
them okay there's a bunch of stuff that
they do to take control these people and
if they act too crazy sometimes they
just whack them okay you don't have to
believe me I'm not going to play the
videos here because the videos are
pretty hard to watch okay but I'll link
it below so you guys can go watch the
original video I made four years ago and
you can look at those videos they are
[ __ ] up of what they do to these
migrants okay me knowing that me knowing
it's like it's a cultural thing they
even say uh Filipina which means like oh
you have a Filipino oh I have an
Ethiopian what do you have like it's
called into the language the ownership
over these people that they are like
not second class [ __ ] third class I
mean no class they're not even citizens
[ __ ] they dogs Pokemons okay the dogs
that clean and come with a few extra
features now that's [ __ ] up for me to
say but that is what it is you're
talking about people whose mouths get
sewn up you talk about people who get
murked you got people who get like
touched however they want to the man
wants like it is what it is so the World
Cup comes around and now you have these
[ __ ] by the thousands getting
offed you're here to work I'm tired the
sun's out I'm dehydrated don't care
throw his body out back they know what
it is
this Stadium
absolutely was built on the backs of
dying people shut up slavery they call
them migrants it's just
it's just it's just to say that they
move it's like I remember when I was in
school and they were talking about
Natives and they said that you know the
natives traded they showed them out that
that's not what happened you know when
they talking about oh well you know they
needed help to harvest everything that
was in this country so they needed help
and they called on the help of Africans
it was not help okay these were not
migrants
when you're migrant you migrate
somewhere you get there you establish
yourself you work and then you do your
thing
when your livelihood is not that's not a
migrant that's a Slave
let's call an apple and let's save a
slave that's a slave that's a goddamn
slave stop well
listen I think slave even for me is a
bit too strong of a term because it's
not like they were to put on a ship and
force their against their will okay they
were obviously pushed there by economic
situations but it borderlines in terms
of the relationship between the person
who runs them and the person who's
working it's not even where you came
from or how you came somewhere you can
come you can come from a country in a
[ __ ] plane if you work and you're not
paid your wage and you have unsanitary
[ __ ] conditions and you're not paid
what you're supposed to pay you're a
slave a slave is not how you came in a
boat that's not the definition of a
slave you can come in a [ __ ]
slave you can come into [ __ ]
spaceship if you want if you're not paid
your wage and you're not paid at all and
you're not fed and they don't care about
your well-being you're a slave even if
you're paying you can be a Slave
what were they saying about slave well
at least you know we feed them we give
them a roof still a slave doesn't matter
it doesn't matter that's not the
definition of a slave so yeah carry on
okay there Mr heated
I'm just saying oh go ahead definition
was wrong go ahead
slave not migrants just say with your
chest
uh and migrant shut up
shut up hmm why are you so heated is the
story that been feeding us like you're
stupid uh yeah the pilgrims they sat
with the Indians and then nah man don't
tell me
don't tell me that the pilgrims that are
sit down with the natives
okay had a little pow wow oh let's share
this is corn oh yeah well this is your
wife that's what it is stop stop
it
it's good yeah this is the same thing
I've heard the same thing when I was in
school I kid you not College shout outs
to you long gay put your [ __ ] you
could leave that [ __ ] and I don't give a
[ __ ]
I remember my teacher told us that
Africans immigrated in the Caribbeans
that was not immigration
okay it's not because you move from one
place to another because you have [ __ ]
up conditions where you were it's good
that you're an immigrant
[ __ ] you're a slave if you work for free
carry on I'm done for real now okay all
right well you guys heard it from preach
first
um
and so when it comes to this world cup
people like ask me my thoughts about it
and none of this is surprising it's like
when you live in these countries two
people can be Indian and the real thing
that differentiates them is the passport
they find out your passport's American
you're American they find out your
passport's Indian [ __ ] uh where why do
you have your passport you're a migrant
why do you have your passport at all
back to work stupid where's your owner
put on this leash that's how it be
okay make no all this talk about
openness and all this other stuff you
know nah nah and I think the media
tiptoes around criticizing some of these
countries and criticizing some of these
places just because you know don't want
to seem islamophobic or whatever it is
but it is what it is
it is what it is
there's a tremendous amount of racism
there's a tremendous amount of
discrimination and that's what these
places are really well known for in a
lot of countries like Ethiopia
that's why I know this is surprising to
me because I've already tackled with
this history a long time ago
sorry
this is like anti-black anti-immigrants
sentiment it's not just the white people
think oh no it's not don't make the
mistake oh if you think it's bad in
North America or the Western World
brother uh you ain't got to where it's
really bad
it's getting spat on doing getting beat
getting put in jail for nope yay it gets
worse
I was I'm following a traveler that goes
around the world yeah and she lists all
the countries that she feels the most
unsafe and the top top ones
are not from the Western World nope nope
so let's keep it a stack it is what it
is about these places they are [ __ ]
shitholes they might have all this money
but in terms of morality they're
bankrupt shitholes now I'm not here to
tell them to change their ways I'm not
here to tell them but I think when it
comes to some International like the
Olympics or the World Cup they shouldn't
be allowed to host it personally
personally this is how I feel about it
now if you have some please that is
talking about unity and everybody should
be accepted and that's what that's what
that's what those events whoa want to
portray
yeah well a country like that shouldn't
host them but that's not that's not
that's not what you live for so this
goes to show you all this talk that
these organizations be it FIFA Olympic
committees do about inclusion safety
lgbtq plus what they don't care moment
somebody comes up big enough check they
bent over and they're like who do I need
to call it who need to call it who I
don't say anything the other day is all
about money so there you guys have it
for Qatar this is a big economic boom
they hope it's going to give them a good
press in the world drawing the attention
of many pure people to immigrate and for
people I mean they just got cut a big
check by oil money so
they win hey must be the money all the
people virtue signaling to talk about I
care about this but you guys are
ambassadors for this world cup you make
me cringe I don't expect the players
because the players are paid to do a job
and represent their country and they're
put in a really tough position but as
far as the ambassadors for a lot of
these causes
you guys are the ones that should be
ashamed the media who didn't do a good
job of portraying and displaying some of
them some of them did documentaries in
their documentation so shout out to them
but a lot of them who waited till Qatar
was happening to voice their concerns
rather than when it was initially given
you guys are such too
right people are like why is it Marcus
that's not his job that's the media's
job to report on it and to stay on that
case but they'd rather go for clicks and
report on Ronaldo 24 7 then actually do
things that is real reporting and it's
unfortunate but that's the world we live
in and it's okay because you know all
the people that are in our DM I'm sorry
come out you should talk about this
should talk about that why don't you
care why don't you care with you and
you're turning on you're waking up at
five in the morning to turn on those
those FIFA World Cups whatever matches
and [ __ ]
you too hashtag YouTube yeah let us know
what you guys think in the comments
below we want to hear from you